David is with us in Raleigh North
Carolina hi David
welcome to the show how can I help I
think if I were you better than I
deserve what's up I'm calling because I
just received this year restricted stock
from the company I work for and so every
year for the next four years
it'll vest and I so I get a fourth of it
every year so this coming year I'll get
about $20,000 and so my question is I
have four credit cards that I want to
pay off and one of them is $20,000 and
then the other three total to $20,000
the first one about 15% interest the
other three are about maybe 25% interest
each so my question is should I you go
ahead and take the short term capital
gain in and pay off the larger one and
then take the other three move it to the
larger one with a balance transfer and
possibly get a zero percent interest for
eighteen months and then start knocking
that one out
or should I do long-term capital gains
and wait so that I take less than that
the long-term capital gains will not
apply to the what the stock is worth at
the time you receive it'll only apply to
what it grows what you get when it
received is an employee benefit that's
going to be ordinary income okay and so
you know if the stock hasn't gone up in
value long term short terms not gonna
matter it's just I think you need to
double check your tax cut pretty crummy
at taxes but I'm pretty sure I'm right
on that
either way I'm cashing the stuff out and
putting it on the debt what's your
household income eighty eight thousand
okay and have you cut up the credit
cards I have not yet are you on a budget
no okay so here's the problem this is
not gonna go away to you do those two
things mm-hmm you've got it being done
with this cuz you cannot out earn your
stupidity I tried it for years
do it and you know so the problem is
you're just you're one off in this based
on only this stock you know benefit and
what we need to do instead is be going
okay we're gonna have a written game
plan by which we get this paid off
oh and their stock there too not like oh
the stocks gonna solve your problem
because the the credit card debt is not
the problem it's the symptom the symptom
of overspending and not having a plan
the symptom of impulsing the symptom of
I want something before I have the money
so I buy it anyway we all have that
right you're not different I'm not
picking on you but what I don't want to
do is go oh yeah use the stock and pay
off the credit cards which is what I
would do I'd pay off the smallest three
immediately and when the other vests I'd
go ahead and pay off other stuff but I
hope by then you've gotten the other
stuff paid off because another year from
now yeah my overall plan is to use what
I get and I'll be able to pay off
everything I have so but that's not
Junior well I'm saying over the next
four years when I have get all this
tested them out okay how much debt do
you have it's a hundred eighty thousand
total minus the house okay and so forty
thousand dollars in credit card doesn't
what else I have a personal loan and HDL
on how BIG's the student sixty thousand
and what do you own your car he I have
two cars me and my wife they are at
least right now but the payoff amounts
or one of them is dirty and the other
ones twenty okay so a hundred and eighty
thousand and your household income is
eighty it might take you four years
you've got forty to throw at it that
rings it down to 140 and probably three
years is what I'd probably rather you do
so list your debts smallest to largest
pay minimum and minimum payments on
everything but the little one stop all
401 K stop all investing stop all
vacations stop
leading out and attack the debts in the
order of smallest to largest one of the
tools that you have to attack the debt
is your income on a tight budget the
other tool that you have the attack the
debt is the stock benefits and so you
can't just what I'm trying to say let's
look at this holistically in your
overall situation and cut up the credit
cards as you get them closed close the
accounts as you get them paid off and
you know let's get them let's get this
wrapped up and moving on so yeah that's
what I would do I would use the stock
immediately on the smallest three credit
cards because they're gonna be your
smallest three debts oh by the way you
need to get rid of these cars that's the
most expensive way to operate a car
according to Consumer Reports Smart
Money Magazine my calculator so hold on
I'll have Kelly pick up I'm gonna send
you a copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover which is the book that shows
you the plan that I just outlined for
you in great detail